welcome to Google cloud on air live
webinars from Google cloud we are
hosting webinars every Tuesday my name
is Ryan McDowell and my name is
mei-chiao hi today we're going to be
talking about stream processing with
cloud dataflow you can ask questions any
time on the platform we have Google ders
on the standby ready to answer them
let's get started today we're going to
talk through stream processing common
patterns with data flow the state and
timer API is and how to take advantage
of them as well as streaming with the
Python SDK before we dive straight into
patterns it's important to understand
why streaming matters and how Apache
beam and dataflow helps you address some
of the common problems within stream
processing so we can have data that
we're processing and that data can be
big for instance we can process
gigabytes to terabytes of data and that
that it could be really really big for
instance we may want to process huge
amounts of data per day and have many
days to process that data could also be
infinitely big so you can be streaming
data and it's constantly coming and it
never stops this gives you a problem
with processing especially when
accounting for unknown delays within
your data so one of the more
difficulties with unbounded data is
unknown delays assuming that every
record has an embedded timestamp
hopefully we would see the records show
up into our system shortly after the
event time here's the record which
happened at 8:00 a.m. in short up in the
system shortly after then we see this
yellow record that was slightly delayed
by a little bit and then finally we see
this green record on the right-hand side
which is significantly delayed it had an
event timestamp of 8:00 a.m. but didn't
show up into our system until 2:00 p.m.
there's many examples why this may
happen so for example imagine a mobile
phone you maybe get on into an airplane
turn on airplane mode be playing your
game the entire time and generating
these game events and then when you get
off the plane you turn off airplane mode
then all the events at that time shoot
up to the cloud and enter your pipeline
so even though the events had occurred
much earlier they actually showed up
into your pipeline much later than
expected so the mobile world introduces
this delay in a pretty big way if you're
performing element-wise transforms for
instance filtering for the yellow
messages that's easy it's just a
continuous transform in this case we
don't care about time we're not doing
any grouping or aggregation in this case
we don't care that's even an unbonded
data set executing transforms in
processing time will be just fine but
what happens when we want to do an
aggregation we may want to see the count
of events per user for batch that's easy
because the data is bounded and
essentially we read in the input and
until we run out of input and then we
omit the count for streaming you can't
do that you never run out of the data so
you can't say we're done processing and
here's the count that I've seen most
commonly what people want to do is
windowing so divide up the data into
some chunks emit the count for that
particular chunk an initial approach to
doing this would be using processing
time windows so for instance when a
record or job shows up into our record
shows up into our job look at the wall
clock do that for a minute and then say
here's the count for that minute
there's many use cases where that is
fine but if you care about the timestamp
within your records you may not get the
grouping you actually want what we
really may want to do is group by the
event time within our data instead of
viewing time as something on the wall
view it as a data stream group by the
event time stamps and output them as we
see them this allows us to perform
calculations over that time interval in
which the events occurred so for example
here taking the events of when they
occurred in processing time and then
shuffling them in regrouping them into
event time windows this allows us to
group data by event time which would be
synaptically more meaningful to our
analytics so I mentioned window in
what is a window all the window is is a
function to divide data into time chunks
within the Apache beam SDK which runs on
data flow we provide several different
window types which allow you to slice
and dice your data in different ways
these are some of the more common ones
so you have fixed windows so you could
think of a fixed window as dividing up
data into fixed periods of time so let's
say twelve to one one to two and then as
soon as you reach the end of that window
compute your aggregation an output
account for that window you also have
sliding windows and these are sort of
like windows fixed windows that overlap
so for instance an element could end up
in many windows so say you have an hour
window that slides by every minute you
may have a window that's 12:01 2 101
1202 to 102 so on and so forth and this
is useful for detecting anomalies on the
incoming data so for instance
determining how many of a record of a
given type showed up in their pipeline
within the past 10 minutes but what if
we wanted to do data dependent when
doing so not look at our data in terms
of time but look at it in terms of
something that is meaningful within our
data such as doing different windows for
every user this is what we would call
sessions here every key is a different
window in sessions are defined by
whenever there's a burst of activity
we're going to capture that burst of
activity and then as soon as there is a
gap in in that activity we'll basically
close that window and then emit it
downstream for processing so that we can
calculate statistics over that window
this is a common thing that you may want
to do in analytics and it's supported
out-of-the-box within the Apache beam
SDK and cloud data flow so we talked
about when doing and we talked about
semantically how we would divide our
data up and compute our calculations but
when does the answer come out this is
problematic because you have to know
when to admit the answer and this is
what we use triggers for
so by default what we have is something
called a watermark the watermark tries
to know everything about our data for a
particular window and to know when we
are done with that so if the watermark
says 12 o'clock it means to the best of
our knowledge there is no data earlier
left than earlier than 12 o'clock and
then we can calculate the time result
for external sources it has to be
somewhat heuristic so for instance
pub/sub we can actually do a read ahead
of the buffer to ensure there's no data
left in it before 12 o'clock before we
actually admit that but if there's a
mobile phone on a plane and it has data
for 11 o'clock in it clearly they don't
have any connectivity we cannot know
about that data that's on their phone so
there has to be some degree of heuristic
to it it can't be perfect just that to
the best of our knowledge we can output
a final count and emit the results here
is an animated gif with the watermark
shown as a dotted line the y-axis is
processing time in the x-axis is event
time the perfect watermark will know
about everything that we haven't seen
perfect watermark actually sees the
future so it can capture data that shows
up significantly later than we
anticipated
for the realistic watermark we can see
that it's pretty good but this one
elements this 9 show that showed up
significantly later we didn't catch it
because we had closed the window since
we were thought we were done processing
data for that time period so what
happens when you have late data how do
you handle it in the Apache beam SDK
there's a way of saying I want to
process late data you can act triggering
to your window to indicate you want to
process that late data so for instance
there's a couple different ways of
processing it I can say I want to
accumulate the processing which means
keep adding to let's say a sum or a
count so if I had let's say a count of
50 before and 2 elements show up after
the watermark then they give me back a
count of 52 I can also say discarding
fired panes which means give me a new
some since the last time I emitted a
result so if I saw 50 on time records in
two elements
late after the watermark then just give
me back the - this is another animation
which shows how we do things with
speculative in late triggers we can
output tentative aggregations before the
watermark has passed and then even with
the heuristic watermark we're able to
update it and update the result and
remit it downstream so sort of saying
sorry here's the actual data that I had
for this time period and this allows us
to capture late data and also emit
speculative data downstream to do our
analytics so now that we understand a
little bit about how stream processing
works let's talk about common patterns
within data flow we'll start out with
exactly once processing so imagine that
we're building a pipeline to ingest
gaming events from our mobile game we'll
start building this pipeline from the
most simple case we want to ingest JSON
data via pub/sub process it within cloud
data flow and then output it to bigquery
we're using pub/sub here because it's a
reliable globally available message
delivery service and we expect our game
to be popular worldwide now if we're
analyzing user behavior duplicate data
which enters our pipeline may throw off
our analytics which makes exactly once
processing fairly critical this is also
critical in other industries you could
think of retail where you may be
processing transactions or finance in
which you may be processing trades
having duplicate data enter your
pipeline and then computing on that
duplicate data can throw off your
analytics and skew your data so if we
were to zoom into the pub sub portion of
our architecture we may presume that it
may cause issues with our system given
its at least once delivery semantics
here the colors indicate unique keys of
Records we can see that's on the right
hand side we may receive duplicates in
the subscriber given the at least ones
delivery however combining pub/sub with
dataflow allows us to achieve exactly
once processing out of the box with a
little effort so how do we do that
well imagine that we have these three
messages here this yellow message we're
zooming in on you can see that it
contains attributes and a payload
message attributes are essentially key
value pairs that you can set on the
header of a message so you could think
of setting a key value pair to do things
like routing a message without having to
deserialize it or reacting to duplicates
within the pipeline the message payload
contains the serialized payload of the
event you'll see that we have a unique
identifier here within the message
payload an event ID so the first step to
actually processing this data in exactly
once fashion we're going to promote that
event ID to the attributes this allows
us to instruct data flow to react to it
within our pipeline if we take a look at
the code for example game event pipeline
it may look like the following we're
applying the pub/sub i/o transform to
read the data from our subscription and
pass it to our transformations here the
transformations represent pardhu
functions you can think of a pardhu is a
map in MapReduce essentially taken in
elements do some transformation on it
and then output the transformed element
in this case when we're consuming from
pub/sub i/o we're just reading the
messages from the subscription so how do
we start reacting to that event ID that
we promote it to the attributes well
it's relatively simple we just add in
the dot with ID attribute field and pass
in the key that we had put in our at
message attributes this allows data flow
to begin reacting to these messages and
then automatically within the pub/sub
i/o transform be able to deduplicate
those messages before sending them
downstream within our pipeline however
this will effectively do duplicate
messages introduced by pub/sub so
messages that are occurring as
duplicates within our system but there's
also another case in which you may
receive duplicates so for instance a
producer publishes a message once and
then they publish it again maybe let's
say several minutes later this will also
handle that case but only within a ten
minute window so for instance if
a publisher published the message at
minute one and then published the same
message at minute three will effectively
duplicate that but we don't keep around
the deduplication table forever so if
they were to publish across you know
multiple hours of timeframes then we may
want to introduce a unique transform to
our pipeline in this case we don't
anticipate that being the case so we can
just duplicate using the width ID
attribute so another common pattern in
data flow is handling schema changes
from the source system for our mobile
game example imagine we have partners
which publish events into our pipeline
there may be cases where those partners
add an additional field to the schema
which they are publishing we don't want
it to be dependent on those partners and
have to coordinate releases so we'll
want to react to that dynamically within
our streaming pipeline looking back at
our messages on the Left we see the
schema which we expect right we have the
same schema that we were processing
before but on the right hand side in the
green message the partner has actually
added an additional field in this case
partner device IP now this additional
field will called cause the insert to
fail and this will cause us to either
drop the message or continually failing
on that message without accounting for
this the record will never make it into
our downstream system so we'll have to
think about how we handle this case well
there's a couple things within bigquery
and data flow that enable us to handle
this with relative ease
so schema changes within bigquery are
additive within the same table so you
can add on fields within that table and
these changes happen online and required
no downtime so there's no effect to
downstream users if we were to submit an
API call to add an additional column to
our table based on the incoming data and
finally the bigquery sink within data
flow allows for the retrieval that
failed inserts so this allows us to
submit records to bigquery then get back
all the failures and then react to them
and do things like add an additional
column to our output table
so zooming in on our pipeline code we
can easily handle changes by retrieving
the failed inserts performing an update
to the schema in real time and then
rewriting those out to bigquery again so
handling changes in this way enables us
to inspect each message for schema
changes and then output the additions to
the bigquery table now we could have
done this in a different way we could
have checked every single message to see
if it's schema had changed but this
would have been quite inefficient
because we would be checking a bunch of
messages that may not have changed
schema so you can imagine that maybe I'm
processing data at a thousand records
per second or a million records per
second inspecting all those messages
where they may head out of change schema
will significantly slow down the
pipeline so doing it in this way allows
us to only inspect and mutate the schema
of those messages which fail insert and
thus react to those schema changes that
are happening upstream so looking back
at our pipeline now we've simply added
the this additional path to process
those errors validate and mutate the
schema and then output to bigquery and
this reduces the operational overhead of
coordinating changes with our partners
and we can automatically update our
pipeline as changes occur so we've added
a lot of functionality to our pipeline
thus far now we can utilize some of the
windowing techniques mentioned earlier
to perform our user analysis here we
don't need to make any adjustments to
our architecture since some of the
strategies that we had mentioned earlier
of with windowing happened within data
flow nothing needed to add to the
architecture so an example of analysis
that we may want to perform is how long
a user spent playing the game and
possibly what caused the user to stop
playing the game now if we were to
utilize fixed windows we may run into
problems because if we are aggregating
over a fixed period of time let's say
like twelve to one o'clock we may have
multiple users using the same device and
then grouping those users together this
grouping would not be accurate when
performing things like how long did the
user spend playing the game how many of
events of a given type did a particular
user
I concur and so it would give us
incorrect correlations over our data so
what we actually want is sessioning with
session windows we can we can achieve
this per user windowing and do analysis
on each of the individual users in this
example for all elements for a key in
this case a user denoted by these three
different colors are included into in
the window until a period of inactivity
once that period of inactivity occurs we
then fire off that window and then
produce our calculate statistics over
that data in this case it gives us
exactly the subdivisions that we need so
now looking at our pipeline code
we window into sessions with a gap of
five minutes so we'll capture activity
until we don't see any activity for five
minutes for a particular user then we'll
key each individual event by the user ID
so that we can do proper groupings on
our data and then we'll group that data
together and then perform analysis on
that those groupings of data so this
enables us to do things like answer that
question of how many are how long did a
user play the game it also allows us to
do interesting things like take
advantage of big queries nested in
repeated fields for instance grouping
together all records for a session into
a repeated field and then having an
aggregate data record sent downstream so
looking at our updated pipeline we've
now added this additional path with the
form analysis you can see now that we're
sessioning by the user or keying by that
user before we group that data together
and then finally we analyzed those
events before we send them downstream
okay so let's talk a bit about the state
API and the timer API in b-team that you
process unbounded large amounts of data
in a globally distributed scale using
the beams portable to model and stateful
processing along with timers adds a new
layer on top of it which enables new use
cases and opens up new efficiencies at
its core stateful and timely processing
happens by augmenting per element
operations per element operations are
the things that we talk such as partes
by adding a mutable state and also
adding a timer API access stateful and
time timely computations are the
underlying patterns that build that
being built upon in other places
precisely because it is the lower-level
api's it allows you to micromanage your
pipelines and your computations to
enable new use cases however at the same
time it's not magic by managing state
and timers that there will be additional
complexes that's built into your
pipelines state API works by adding
scalability and consistency on top of a
finely grained stateful processing this
is built on top of beams portability it
it works following setting per key state
that's accessible within per element
transforms with this API Pardo's and any
other per element transforms can access
a mutable state that is backed by a
datastore and can read and mutate this
data in a concurrency safe way and
similarly timer api all laws the state
will do funds to set timers either in
the processing time domain or in the
event time domain to get callbacks based
on some timer event that's customizable
by the users and timer callbacks also
have access to the same exact stateful
APs
so let's look at the details of the
implementation so first thing is state
is partitioned by key and window and
what do we mean by that is the stateful
part do in the middle of that pipeline
has access to a data store and given an
element the runner will auto-detect the
window and the key that's associated
with that element and that stateful
partner will be able to access a state
cell within this data store and why is
it important that state is partitioned
along the windowing domain in addition
to the key domain is this all those
runners to clean up once Windows expires
it's possible for runners to go and
clean up the state store this is really
important because otherwise the runners
will have the keeps state forever during
the runtime of the pipeline there are
additional concentrations that comes
with partitioning the state Burkean per
window one concentrations
since the there are concurrency
guarantees and the partition happens per
client per window that could mean that a
runner need to shuffle data to a single
worker in order to execute within the
context of aberjian per element so there
are two implications to that first
implication is there could be shuffling
the second implication is that there is
a limit to paralyzation it it's possible
that within the same key and same window
the runner will be forced to execute
serially and the other implication of
this comes in the storage and fault
tolerance area since we are partitioning
perky and per window that means that the
state stone is to keep state perky and
per window if there will be a lot of
keys and windows that means that there
will be a proportional increase in the
storage used and the corollary of that
is if you want to get a lot of
parallelism into your system you could
partition a lot within the key or within
the window or in any combination of
those two so let's look at an example to
clarify a little bit here we are talking
about looking at a regular do phone
it takes a key value input and returns
some other thing and the first thing
that you will notice is there is a tag
your state ID which uses an identifier
index here index is a mutable state cell
that is partitioned by key on window and
if you go down a little bit and look at
the process element function in the
argument list you will see the same
state ID tag with a matching index
identifier at the execution time runner
will pass us the state cell that we can
access and because of the matching in
matching identifiers that will be the
exact same thing as we defined if you
look at the body of the process function
it is a three line function first thing
you should notice is the second line is
just a regular Devon syntax it is
outputting an element based on its
symbols the first line within the method
body it's it's reading an integer that
is stored in the state cell and the
third line is updating this value by
writing it on top of it since being
runners provides the concurrency
guarantees writing into the same state
will be guaranteed to not try it on top
of an undefined values and another thing
I would like to talk about here is the
the type of the state if you notice the
type of the state the index is an
integer here and since I said that the
runners may need to shuffle data across
workers the state value needs to be
serializable in this case the integer
values serializable and we are using
your warrant coder to ensure that so the
important part to get here is whatever
you put in your state it's up to you
however it needs to have a color that
that that could serialize the type of
your state information let's tie this a
little bit with the timer API what does
timeman api do any stateful dufan could
set timers and timers could be triggered
in the processing time or in the event
time so what do we mean by that Thomas
could be triggered within the processing
time
that means that a stateful dufan can set
a timer that will trigger let's say a
minute from now or a stateful dupont can
set a timer in the event time and what
that could be mean is a dufan could
request a timer to trigger when the
timestamps of the elements being
processed reaches a certain timestamp
time will events has access to the same
state information and have access to the
same mutable state data and in
combination they are not really powerful
scenarios so this this is a combined
example we are looking at right now and
again this is a regular dufan function
it's just stateful do file function you
can notice the state ID tags on a bunch
of variables and one thing that is
different here is the timer ID tag we
are using timer ID tag to create a new
timer in this case our timer has an
identifier called expiry and the other
thing to notice here is timer was
created in the event time domain so that
means that we can use this timer to set
triggers that will trigger in the event
time domain if you look at our process
method in the argument list that would
be one new argument that is the timer ID
tag with the same exact identifier
expiring a beam runner will pass us this
timer and it will do the matching python
based on the matching identifier of
expiring within the body of the blue
phone it is possible to do any of your
regular blow for logic after that before
that or in between that you can access
state api's and timer api's in this case
that do phone is setting a timer that's
going to trigger after the end of the
window plus some old old lateness and
one thing I'd like to point out here is
we are setting this timer within the
process element function and this is
happening for every element this is fine
because setting and resetting timers in
bean timer ApS is not an expensive
operation
let's go down a little bit to look at
our callback method the method called on
expiry will be our callback method and
beam runners identify this and
understand this by the tag on timer on
timer text tags are called dog method
used by the action of using the same
identifier that's expiry meme runner
can't match this callback event to the
timer that we were already using and
within the argument list of this
callback method you will notice that it
actually has access to one of the state
in the state cells so this is because
timer callbacks have regular access to
the state ApS and to summarize what's
happening within this callback method it
is reading some input information from
the state adding some management and
outputting as usual so in combination
this example uses state API timer API
demonstrate callbacks and demonstrate
use of state and timer tags
I would also like to talk a little bit
about the Python SDK within beam within
the context of the date of loss
streaming part o streaming is one of the
latest offerings artists to me beta was
large in July 2018 from alpha to beta we
made significant improvements in
performance and stability and in terms
of the amount of beam model that is
supported in its current state artists
streaming SDK for Apache beam supports
all of P model it all loves reading from
cloud pops up it all loves writing to
cloud pops up and it o loves writing to
cloud bigquery and what is on our
roadmap one thing that's on our roadmap
is continuing to improve performance and
stability of Python streaming the next
thing is will we are planning to add
more and more arrows that is adding
support for other cloud Google cloud
data sources and as well as other open
source data sources such as Apache Kafka
another feature that is on the roadmap
is called cross language transforms this
is one of the most exciting features
cross language transforms all our
accessing to transforms or iOS that are
written within other languages with
cross language transforms it will be
possible to use Python SDK to use any of
the areas that were already developed
and has been used for a while within the
Java SDK so this will open up Python SDK
users to a large new set of fours the
next thing we we have on our roadmap is
adding support for all the cloth
dataflow service features these are the
cool features that make people use
manage cloud dataflow service to execute
their bean pipelines so one of those
features is auto scaling or - scaling or
loss picking just the right amount of
workers automatically for cloud dataflow
jobs so this will be one of the features
that we are planning to add for Python
streaming and finally Python tree
support this is a long time requested
feature we are building this into the
Python
streaming and also for Python batch and
this is one of the this is this
concludes one of the major items of
sonar roadmap and I also like to talk
about runners where you can run Python
streaming today you can run Python
streaming SDK on cloud dataflow this is
supported at a beta level you can use
the direct runner for local execution
direct Runner is a really cool feature
that's a pretty complete runner that can
execute Python SDK pipelines within a
single computer it's great for testing
and developing new pipelines and another
thing is there there is work going on to
enable Python streaming SDK to work on
other open-source runners Apache flames
will be one of them so this will just
expand on the synergy of Apache beam by
combining other open-source projects
together and tying them together so
let's let's look at how a Python
streaming word count example works the
first thing to notice within this
example is it is the usual batch word
counter example with just a few
differences if very first difference is
the first line that is a read that's an
operation to read from pops up cloud
pops up see streaming's source and we
are subscribing to a subscription here
to read incoming messages as they come
along so this will be a streaming job
and as long as the job is running it
will be reading new messages from cloud
pops up as it arrives the other
difference that I would like to point
out is the second to last line that is a
write operation - cloud pops up again
cloud pops up is a streaming pipe and
reading and writing into that requires a
streaming job in this case once the
inputs are processed we are writing them
back into the club pops up in a
streaming fashion beyond that there are
really no other differences it is read
from an area that the stream
I do the usual processing right back to
an IO that support streaming and just a
quick highlight for the people who are
not very familiar with Python SDK here's
window into is the transform that we use
for windowing that is the same things
that we started talking about at the
beginning of this presentation
the other interesting thing here is work
by key which respects the windowing as
it's defined in the previous window mean
to transform and groups elements into
the the categories that's based on the
key and the window and finally all the
other transforms that are mentioned here
map Pardo are element based transforms
these they do operation based on a given
element and they produce some number of
other elements and to tie up with the
previous segment in Python SDK currently
doesn't have support for state and
primary api's but that's one of the
things that on our feature list that we
would like to add as we advance through
our roadmap so with that we conclude the
Python streaming related part so stay
tuned for live Q&A we'll be back in less
than a minute
you
all right thank you for the questions so
I will read the questions from the
audience and start answering them the
first question is what kind of Windows
do I have is it limited fixed is it
limited to fixed sliding and session
windows in in beam windowing is just an
API it's possible to build any sort of
custom windowing functions that
satisfies your use case being by default
comes with these two types of windows
fixed sliding and session but there's no
limit on how to build or what kind of
Windows to use you can look at some of
our examples to find how to build your
own custom windows the the next question
is what are some trade-offs with various
triggers triggers at its core all of you
to customize treating one latency second
cost and third accuracy think of a use
case where you are trying to show the
top ten users for a mobile game
leaderboard what you probably need is
low latency so that your users show new
data quickly occurs it might not be very
important and you probably want to
reduce your costs and in a different
case let's say this is a billing example
that you want to get amount of full
billing yet to enough amount in this
case probably latency doesn't matter
that much if you get your data and hour
later the mountains will be okay but do
you really want full precision in terms
of how your billing comes out and cost
probably doesn't matter that much
so triggers all of you to customize in
these three dimensions the next question
is where do I go to find more examples
so the Apache beam SDK on github
actually has an examples directory and
within this directory you can find
examples for simple things like word
count all the way up to complex things
like running sub processes within a
pardhu function we also provide dataflow
templates so dataflow templates are
selectable on the cloud console UI
within a drop-down so you can say you're
ingesting data from pub/sub and you just
want to output that to bigquery you
don't really have that many
transformations that you want to do
you just want to get that data into your
system you can go to the data flow
council UI and just select that from a
drop-down but we also published these
templates on github underneath the
Google cloud platform data flow
templates repository the next question
is what are some other common patterns
well we actually have a blog series on
common patterns within cloud dataflow
you can find these within the Google
cloud platform blog I believe they're
called use case in patterns common use
cases and patterns within cloud dataflow
in you know just to mention some of the
other ones that you may find there
should be like dealing with bad data you
know how do I make calls to an external
database how do I merge windows together
and how do I handle composite keys for
like a group by key so check out those
blogs to find out more information about
the common patterns within data flow the
next question is very state stored and
traditionally in data flow there's an
agent that handles storing of state and
how it was implemented initially was it
used local disks of the virtual machines
however with the introduction of
streaming engine some of these things
are stored in its own cloud service so
it depends what you use it's it's
possible that your local disk is used or
depending on if you are using streaming
engine it will be stored in a another
cloud service the next question is when
do I use the state API versus another
hosted service so as you can imagine
storing state in the pipeline itself
when do I use that versus storing state
in an external store such as cloud big
table or or Redis or a memory store well
essentially store in the state with in
your pipeline allows you to have low
latency reads and writes from from that
from that state and it allows you to
keep that state only for a particular
period of time so say during your window
so if you're using another hosted
service you may accumulate that state
over time and have to do manual cleanup
another benefit of this is that data
flow actually manages the state for
as you saw in the code earlier all I
call is read States or write States I
don't have to worry about setting up any
infrastructure I don't have to worry
about managing that infrastructure or
monitoring it because it's all handled
on the back end but Google clouds
dataflow service and the last question
on the list is what are the limitations
of state API in terms of latency size or
anything else there as we just talked in
one of our previous questions state
itself is stored either on local disk or
in a different service so adding a lot
of size to your state will mean that the
constable amount of data is moving just
because it's part of the state so if you
are in one of these cases you could
consider we are collecting your partner
and such that some of this data is
actually part of your main input data in
terms of latency again the data the
state needs to be shuffled across
workers so there will be some amount of
latency but it would not be a
considerable amount and the final thing
that you should be considering is as we
mentioned during your presentation is
that the state data itself needs to be
serializable so as long as you pick a
type that is serializable you can use
any type of information for your state
so with that we wrap up the questions
stay tuned for the next session
how API products accelerated Walgreens
digital transformation to the cloud
thank you
you